[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like over a year ago introduced to
bethere image ginjuries not only late
King Robert's bastard but read Robertson
sirs his firstborn and illegitimate son
the black haired one that supposedly
died of a fever I lost my first boy he
was a fighter too tried to beat the
fever that took him however one of my
viewers pointed out in the comment
section that season 7 provided more
clues supporting this theory and so I
decided to update this theory with a few
great points before I introduced with
the new hints and clues let's first take
a look on the clothes we had before from
the very first season we've known the
injuries son of King Robert Baratheon as
Ned Stark recognized it at the moment he
laid his eyes on him just like when a
Shogun jury son of King Robert in the
books as well however the show also
provided quite a few clues leading to a
possibility that ginjury isn't just
Roberts bastard but rather legitimate
son of King Robert and Queen Cersei but
his theory ginjuries a black haired
beauty sanded Cersei described to
Kathleen in the second episode of the
very first season Asajj she said he died
of a fever when arya asked injury about
his mother the only thing he remembered
was her yellow hair the same he already
told to her father but this time did she
also mention that his mother worked in a
tavern then we also have a scene image
search he remembers how she used to
disguise herself as a tavern wench when
she had secret meetings with Jaime do
you think it's a coincidence that Ginty
remembers his yellow hair matter who he
said looked like some tavern wench
well sir she on the other hand said
herself that she was dressing as one toe
with other people recognizing her well
it certainly might be a coincidence
but having in mind that this is Game of
Thrones the show in which almost every
spoken word has a meaning there might be
something more just like man did Stannis
also recognize the ginjuries Robert son
as soon as he laid his eyes on him upon
arriving at Dragonstone Stannis briefly
looked over ginjury and confirmed that
he is clearly Robert's son looking just
like he did at that age this matches
with Cersei statement that her by her
beauty son look just like Robert just
like him
basically this series replaced the real
baby who would be ginjury with some
common lowborn baby then she poisoned
that lowborn baby causing its death
having in minded the fever caused
child's death serfs probably use the
same poison Petyr Baelish and lights
Iran used to kill Jon Arryn the one that
causes fever and results with death
recall that in The Dance with Dragons
first claims to has reached beggars son
with
another baby so infant swabs have
happened before I'm sure most of you are
wondering how does he manage to do all
of that without being noticed by robert
baratheon
after all sir she mentions that Robert
was present when their son's body was
taken away so how could Cersei have sent
her child away without her husband
noticing it this was actually very
simple to manage since Robert never
attended any of Circe's child births
Cersei stated herself Robert would
always go hunting when she was about to
give birth and when he would return
Cersei would present him with the baby
and he would present her with the
snake's head what was hunting that was
customer whenever my time was near my
royal husband would flee to the trees
with his huntsmen and his hounds when he
returned he would present me with some
pelts or a stag's head and I would
present him with a baby with Robert of
a-hunting Cersei would have easily
replaced her son with either poisoned
lowborn baby and presented to Robert
when he returned from the hunt I'm also
wondering if Janrain who visited ginjury
a few times before his death actually
Farah that ginjuries the first and true
born son of his dear friend King Robert
Baratheon
but if conversation between Cersei and
Jaime and John's funeral image search
expressed concern for their lives in
case John told the truth Robert was the
truth about his first than the only true
born son but who would he tell my
husband if he told the King both I had
to ask you and city gates by now
whatever Jon Arryn knew what didn't know
it died with him
could it be that Cersei and Jaime were
worried that Jon might have told someone
the truth about her the firstborn child
rather than the truth about her
incestuous relationship with Jaime
that's definitely the case in my opinion
pay attention how Jaime only mentions
that he and Cersei would be executed if
Robert found out the truth wouldn't it
be them and all three of their children
that would be executed if Lord Elrond
found out the truth about their
incestuous relationship
long story short Ned thought he found
out the same truth Lord Arryn dead but
he might have been wrong as I believe
the most important truth Jon knew was
the truth about ginjury I know the truth
Jon Arryn died for
do you know the stock it will also raise
a question about Lord Aaron's death
which we all know was orchestrated by
Littlefinger
what if Petyr Baelish killed the hand of
the king of course beside the fact that
it gave me an opportunity to marry Liza
who has already been manipulating with
but also to prevent Lord the rain to
tell the truth about ginjury to Robert
but why would have a little finger even
done that
what good is bring to him in this theory
well if Lord the rain had managed to
tell King Robert about his only true and
other son it would not have brought
Peter chance to put the Seven Kingdoms
into the state of chaos from which he
personally benefited it would not have
brought him a chance to serve war
between the lions and wolves it would
not have brought him a chance to
manipulate with Ned Stark which had
resulted just as is planned with war if
Lord Arryn had told to King Robert about
ginjury Robert would have executed
Cersei and Jaime lanes friend would have
still been alive
Ginji would have been his heir Lord
Arryn wouldn't have been killed that
stark would not have become the hand of
the king and the Seven Kingdoms would
not have been in the state of chaos
which would not have brought any success
and benefit to Littlefinger Cersei also
never mentioned the child's name which
could be a deliberate move on the show
honors behalf to keep his identity a
secret
it's also interesting how ginjury grew
up in the slums of flea bottom and yet
managed to land the job with the most
prestigious armor in King's Landing it's
said that when he was old enough an
unknown highborn person pay his
apprentice face so he could learn to be
a blacksmith having in mind that Robert
had never even known of his existence
then what hybrid person was helping
injury in my opinion it was his mother
herself Cersei Lannister
sirs his love of her bloodline combined
with her hatred for Robert and
unconditional love of her children made
her give away Roberts child rather than
have him killed now let's take a look on
the new clues that season 7 provided and
one of my viewers pointed out it says
hey fire in blood I'm enjoying your
videos and I particularly like the
ginjury being Circe's by her beauty son
that supposedly died before the events
of Game of Thrones theory
here are some seasons some hints to
support is amazing theory even more
gingers arrived right under the nose of
Cersei literally as her loyal blacksmith
warm saline stir army all these years
now let me remind you the ginjury being
back at King's Landing after escaping
Dragonstone was an idea that was seaward
as he believed he'd be saved there since
the gold cloaks don't know his face
however was he really being a notice
there as a viewer points out he probably
was not sir she tells Jaime that she
allowed the meeting between Jamie and
Tyrion happen
additionally she then goes on to say do
you think anything
happens in the city without me knowing
it this is exactly what happened in
season 7 episode 5 and Jamie confessed
that he met Tyrion Circe already had
known every detail regarding of how the
meeting happened and what they talked
about punish him Syrian bran he betrayed
you he set up a meeting without your
knowledge or consent do you think
anything of importance happens in the
city without me knowing you let it
happen why I've come to believe that an
accommodation with the Dragon Queen
could be on our immediate interest the
point about Cersei knowing everything of
importance happening in her city is
valid
whoever then concludes that this
statement basic confirms that she
allowed us to meet up with ginjury and
smuggle him out of the King's Landing
let me stop right there and say that
this point is most probably true that
was came to King's Landing material and
since Cersei knows about hearing coming
to her Syrian meeting up with Jaime it's
safe to say that she kept track endow us
as well that was Seaworth is basically
hand of the King in the north
and therefore Cersei most probably
didn't just let him walk to her City
without being spied on services to Jaime
that she allowed the meeting between him
and Tyrion happened because it's in her
interest to set an arrangement with the
Dragon Queen but why did she allow us to
smuggle ginjury out of the capital the
viewer points out that answer is she won
again jury to me Davi Tyrion this way
she wanted to convince Tyrion that Ginji
would be a better king and ruler than
the met king's daughter who already
started burning down people against
tyrants advice a few episodes later in
their conversation in season 7 episode 7
search simplicity Rhian that then is not
a good monarch she hoped for the back
door conversation and dealer would
happen next and for all we know they
might have agreed to make search his
only remaining son the King already made
a video about turns backdoor deal with
Cersei and the possibility of him
betraying Daenerys sense siding with
Cersei it's quite possible the Tyrion
Cersei agreed to make her sacred son the
king after professing his love for
sources deceased children and realizing
his sister was pregnant Tyrion appears
too soft and just before the camera cuts
away from the scene altogether in what
could have been his final moments
however tyranny insisted asserts that
his goal was never to destroy House
Lannister and he tried to paint his
actions including the homicide of Inns
own father in a way that inspired
sympathy from his sister
make no mistake the fact that Tyrion
doesn't want to destroy the Lannisters
is a major confession and it could
confirm that he will betray or even has
already betrayed Danny a tense meeting
between Cersei and Tyrion finally took
place in season 7 but it's what happened
off screen that matters most the next
time we see these two characters is
during their return to the dragon pit
Cersei suddenly willing to help John and
Dana in their battle against the White
Walkers or at least it appeared that way
Cersei later explained to Jaime that the
whole alliance thing was a lie having
just seen tear and emphasized the value
of a good lie to Jon Snow it's
reasonable to believe he's stressed to
his sister behind closed doors following
the episode and Tyrians ominous look at
the end quite a big amount of fans began
coming up with the same theory
Tyrion cut a deal with Cersei he knew
she wasn't going to go north and he told
her to lie about it
even the scene in which Cersei real
scripture intention to Jaime could be
seen as a proof that Tyrion has already
betrayed Danny Circe says to Jaime you
were always a dunce Lannister this is a
reference to him falling for life but
Tyrion was also Darrin is also Lannister
if he fell for Elias well it would be an
odd phrase for her to use I feel like
her attitude and phrasing implies that
Tyrion was in on the line it's quite
possible that here in Cersei also agreed
to make her sacred son ginjury the king
the next point is sources promised a
yeren Cersei promised during that she
would marry him mattered the war is won
why would she agree to such a deal she
knows that you're an already kill his
own brother to take the throne of the
Iron Islands and certainly would not
think twice to kill her as well and take
the throne once they get married
the explanation is it's all part of her
plan after she wins the war she will
reveal the true identity of ginjury
huran Robert's firstborn that everyone
believes died of a fever and make him
her last living son a king then she can
and would marry urine fulfilling her
promise and thus protecting the Iron
Throne from being hijacked by urine this
would also ensure safety since her son
is the king and she would also remain
the powerful Queen the viewer then goes
on by saying that during the seasons
extending during her coronation scene
there's one more final clue sir she
gives Jaime reluctant grave look this
means she doesn't want the Iron Throne
she wants ginjury on it however she
doesn't want to lose her remaining child
in Game of Thrones like she lost her
other three so she decides to play the
game for herself
eliminate all her rivals and then reveal
the identity of ginjury her firstborn
son and make him King this is her plan
and endgame in season one sir says she
lost her firstborn black haired son in
highlights
he was a fighter in season seven Ginja
says the John that he's a fighter nice
for shadow there I lost my first boy I
took black-haired beauty he was a
fighter too tried to beat the fever that
took him said Ava's told me where you're
going
your grace and why let me come with you
don't be a fool you're not a soldier no
I'm a fighter I hope that me that those
points are truly adding more fuel on an
already well-received theory in the game
terms community in conclusion judging by
all those close skins and proves there's
a huge possibility that the ginjury is
not just a bastard but rather a trueborn
son of King Robert Baratheon and Queen
Cersei Lannister be aware that this is a
theory for a TV show only not for the
books in the book Cersei did become
pregnant by Robert but she did not give
birth to that child unwilling to give
birth to Robert shell she sent out Jaime
to find a woman to Cleanser having grown
to resent Robert over years sir Stephen
took care to ensure he did not
impregnate her so again G being serfs
his son certainly is not possible in
books since the little dark-haired boy
that Cersei gave birth to in the show
does not exist in books and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]